well Skylar for you when you were
presented with the script for cavemen
where do you like you know what there's
there's too many sex scenes family might
be watching my families see me do some
stuff and I do with you know the role
calls for and thankfully the role had so
many redeeming qualities that the and
and by the way like the sex scenes that
are in the movie they're not they're not
a they're not real so that's good be
they're also kind of not perfect they're
not like beautiful at all they're a
pretty dysfunctional and like calm it's
comedy first so I can I loved playing a
moment that has you know levity to it
interesting scene like I mean are you
doing any type of rehearsal time with
these things because you were an active
boy in the film sure you did have some
interesting scenarios so sure do you to
remember any interesting moments someone
said like I don't think I remember was
sleeping and with the enemy Julia
Roberts had everybody take off their
clothes oh yeah yeah three weeks go go
go go go try and get the coverage for
every scene and trying the scenes done
trying get the day done there was no
time to come up with some creative way
over there was no time for that there
was no like Frank so I mean we read
through everything but we're not like
when you do a sex scene or something
like that you're not rehearsing that
part of it you know it's that's for the
day like you're not like hey come over
later I have a private rare like dress
rehearsal yeah or undress rehearsal yeah
not the case no you've been very busy I
was looking at your IMDB page and you
have a lot of things in post and pre how
do you keep yourself looking so
beautiful and composed in a sort of
jackieo way and and and rushing around
I'm sure you have so much on your plate
what can you advise another la actor on
sort of just keeping level-headed
because it's easy in the city
to get really is I think it's valuing
your private life following your life at
home and taking that time for yourself
everyday even if it's just in the
morning you wake up a little bit earlier
and if it's your if exercise you makes
you feel good do that if going on for a
hike makes you feel good do that but
spending time with your family or
friends like take that time it's so
important to get time for yourself
because if not you're constantly in this
we love working and you're traveling in
your with people that's it and talking
about yourself all day it's just it can
get to be very consuming and
self-involved and if you don't take that
time to do something that makes you feel
good it can be really quite a downfall I
think yeah I agree things that make you
stay grounded I just took a trip to New
York just to like be with my family for
the Superbowl and my brother and I
caught a UFC fight like hobbies are
important like this isn't all we do this
is all we do right now to make money and
for a living and it's what we love to do
but you know I like to play tennis or
sit on my couch and watch The Bachelor
with my girlfriend like that's a fun
thing for me to do eat food yeah yeah
yeah well there's a great line in the
film to that la men play a lot of games
and I'm sure la women have their own
tricks up their sleeves so if you were
gonna coach a room of LA bachelors about
going out cheese what finding I don't
know I I had so many cynical jokes in my
head right there but I'll try to I'll
try to do it well I mean I just say like
come on man like no pickup lines okay
just no pickup lines do not press too
hard in a situation let it come to you a
little bit and guess what if it's not
gonna be met halfway then it's not meant
to be so relax take an opportunity when
you see it but just like have low
expectations and you will be certainly
surprised
anything for the ladies I I kind of
agree with what you're saying for women
too because I think I see a lot of my
guy friends the girls sometimes now can
be so overwhelming and really in your
face and really pushy and they don't
like that it's great for maybe one night
but not to be in a relationship with and
I think that a lot of value in having
self-respect and dignity and and being
yourself don't try and act like someone
else or pretend you like all these
different things cuz the guy likes it
know be who you are
likely what you like and the right
person will come along
unapologetically be yourself yes which
brings me back to the bachelor it's like
I just make this all that laughter think
about it those girls are going crazy for
this guy it's like have some
self-respect